they call this place the Galapagos of
the Arctic
where wildlife rarely comes into contact
with humans and where glaciers slowly
crawl to meet the sea these are the
images that define this wilderness at
the top of the world and man's impact on
earth is causing the Arctic to melt
we're boarding the Greenpeace vessel
Arctic sunrise its activists want to
show us what this melting means for the
Arctic and its ecosystems and to see
what's below the surface here we have to
go down to the bottom of the ocean 200
meters to the sea floor where 10 meters
off one alone this is the ultimate in
here with 10 meters off the sea
there is now evidence to support the
claim that ecosystems like these are
being damaged daily in the Arctic
melting sea ice here means the ocean is
more accessible than it ever has been
before that's good news for the fishing
fleets that are moving into the Arctic
Greenpeace has been using camera drones
to get a view of the trawlers and the
gear they use the nets are described by
some ecologists as bulldozers on the sea
floor which damaged the coral and the
sea life the Arctic sunrise is looking
for a British trawler called coachella
registered in Hull it is one of the
biggest trawlers there is cod is in high
demand from the UK in particular a
hundred thousand tonnes is imported each
year to feed our love of fish and chips
who gets done right now doing three and
a half knots and trolling in about two
they're hopeful the crew will talk to
them about their plans to fish in this
area and we do not have a visual of her
although it's a little bit foggy you're
going to ask her a few questions
Coachella Coachella this is Arctic
sunrise on channel 10 how do you read me
I got your phone how long has your troll
being down and when do you expect that
you'll be bringing it up again I'm sorry
I'm very busy either
translational strategy see if there's
anything about two GU corner 16 plus
nothing except for inverted yoga the
crew of the Coachella may not have had
time to talk to Greenpeace but when the
troller begins to haul it brings out 40
tons of cod there is nothing illegal
about what this ship is doing well this
is the consequence of Britain's
insatiable appetite for cod trawlers
like this one a British trawler going
further and further north into the
Arctic to supply demand an environmental
campaigners say that movement North has
to stop now if the fragile ecosystem
around the Arctic is to be saved
and this is what's left on the sea floor
after a trawler has been through the
horizontal lines are the tracks from the
netgear any marine life that lived here
before has likely been destroyed the
seafloor is a is a complex place there
are a lot of things living above it
there are hard corals and they may be
many centuries old until the day that a
net just snaps them off and then that's
it for centuries even if the Nets don't
come back so here there is a chance to
get it right there has been progress the
UK's leading retailers and supermarkets
and some of the world's largest fishing
companies have struck a deal to protect
parts of the Arctic as yet unfished this
agreement is as fragile as the ecosystem
it's designed to protect the norwegian
government has a very clear
responsibility to make sure that there
is protection of the areas that are
vulnerable and that are opening up there
is a new ocean that is emerging and what
the eyes used to protect is now in a way
up for grabs if we let it happen no one
is saying no fishing just saying not
everywhere and not not unlimited the
future of the Arctic is a story which
hasn't really been written yet its
resources are in high demand and it will
be how that demand is managed that
decides the Arctic's fate Nick Martin
Sky News the Arctic